kristina is with us in Bethlehem
Pennsylvania
hi Kristina how are you hi I'm good how
are you
better than I deserve what's up I've
been watching your show now for probably
about three days and I came across you
on Pinterest but I wasn't really
concerned about my dental after I got
married in October and Lauren me alone
actually I'm in about $30,000 worth of
debt and I'm currently out of work due
to a concussion from my last previous
job and I haven't decided to go back to
work because I have a son history and my
husband said it wasn't worth it paying
the daycare but I'm just wondering is it
realistic that he can pay it off himself
and also where do I even begin to get
all this demolished mmm Wow so what is
your husband's income um he actually
just got away seven years so we're
looking at about 45 thousand a year
mm-hmm okay and you have $30,000 and
what kind of debt student loans actually
that's only 10 grand the rest of its
credit cards and medical okay cool what
were you making at your job I was making
probably around 30,000 you know with day
care and everything else you're not
making a bunch above that he's he's
partially right about that is your
desire to be at home or to be in the
work place I would like to do something
productive but I say this money was not
right for my son home with me okay well
is there anything that says you can't be
doing some kind of a side hustle
business from home I actually started to
two weeks ago just ladies in church lets
me clean our house like once weekly but
its own that's nothing right now and
once it picks up it would be something
but right now it's just like paying gas
or really yes mm-hmm
well you know if you picked up three or
four houses that be handy get several of
those right yeah I'm hoping for yeah
that'd be good you probably make more
than 30 Graham doing that if you watch
what you're doing and have control of
your time
you wouldn't be necessarily chained to a
desk right yeah that would be pretty
cool so that's something to think about
so yeah I mean anything we can do to
help throw money on this because paying
off $30,000 making forty five you know
the family of three it can be done but
it's you got a tight budget the reason
we actually looked into our debt after
Austin got married my husband's main
goal was to buy a house we were supposed
to move out Elisa's up in March and we
were gonna buy a house but his credit
wasn't where it should be
let me check out two more credit cards
and now his credit is actually below
what it was and we thought it would be
up so we just don't know from here yeah
you need to get out of that and then
build your emergency fund and then save
for your down payment for your house so
it's gonna be a little while for you buy
a house probably two three years right
that's gonna be wise anyway it's gonna
be the best route to go because you've
got this thirty thousand dollars you
need to clean up you get the credit
cards out and chop them up time for
plastic surgery and then get your family
on a written budget produce every dollar
make every dollar behave good jump
online at every dollar calm and download
the app for your iPhone or Android and
he gets on it to the two of you look at
it you say where's our money going what
can we do to make the money that we have
behaved well can we do to make more
money he picks up some extra income you
pick up some extra income you list your
debts smallest to largest you attack
your debts in that order as fast as you
possibly can and when that first one's
gone then you attack the next one down
when that one's going you attack the
next one down but if we do a little math
fifteen thousand a year for two years
would have you debt free right that's
about fifteen hundred bucks a month
that's what it's gonna take
and that's gonna be tight on a forty
five hundred dollar at forty five
thousand dollar income so I mean you're
you can add some things to the income he
can add some things to the income and
you're not going out to eat again not if
you want a house not if you want to get
this mess cleaned
because this is going to stick around
for a decade if you don't deal with it
so you're wise to call me and say I'm
ready to deal with it hold on I'm gonna
give you a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover which will show you
exactly what to do and when to do it how
to do it to get this mess cleaned up but
the two of you are going to get on the
same page and now I'm really glad you
did not get a house you can't afford a
house house would have been a curse for
you right now and but I mean the house
would have got you instead of you get in
the house so I want you to get after it
and you know in a very very real way hey
thanks for calling in